[Music]
laura is with us laura is in montreal
canada hey
laura how are you good how are you
better than we deserve how can we help
um
you're breaking up try again
hello hello try one more time you're
breaking up
okay no worries um my question i'm
really clueless right now to be honest
um so my parents have an 18-year
age difference and there
is a so obviously recently we've had
some
conversations about wills and things
like that
and my family has a cottage it's really
important to us
it's been in our family for generations
and it really means a lot to our
everyone in our family
however i was speaking to my mom who
doesn't uh she doesn't have a job and
she
expressed that she would be interested
in selling it
after god forbid the passing of my
father especially if she needed money
and i'm really wondering
what is the what right as a child do you
have to interfere in that
none if any zero it's not your stuff
yeah why do you think you do laura
i don't know it's just so hard seeing
something that meant so much
to everyone in our family possibly
not you know being in our family how
much is it worth
a lot um it's just done a really good
piece of land for probably upwards to a
million
well why don't you sell some of the land
and keep the cottage
but would i be able to suggest that or
is that well you could buy the cottage
and ask them to carve out just a few
acres and keep the cottage itself
because it's not the farm that means
something to you it was the it was the
lake part of it right
yeah it's just generally having even a
piece of it you know just the
just the memories that are attached to
the the area
i guess that is a good idea it's just
rough it's hard to like i
have offered to even like give support
if needed like i would be fine
giving financial support obviously to my
family
how old are you i'm 26.
okay what do you make um just under 70.
that's great all right and your dad is
how old
um my dad is in his mid-60s now
okay all right well uh let's pretend you
got 20 years
before this really comes up he gets to
his mid 80s
okay uh that would give you time to
prepare
if this means a lot to you to build some
wealth and be able to offer to buy it
yeah and it would be certainly okay for
you to
ask that you be given the option to buy
it in the will
should they get that you'd be given
first route of refusal or a
an option to purchase it uh first option
to purchase it or something like that so
that they didn't just call you up one
day and go we sold it
you know instead you got you you know
because you'd saved up a half million
dollars and you could have bought half
the property and
uh had them sell off the other half or
something like that and
that would have scratched your itch and
then you then at that point you become a
customer of the estate
not someone who just feels entitled to
it agreed
i agree yeah just have the conversation
but i wouldn't go in there saying hey
this is what i want this is what needs
to be done
just absolutely you don't have any
rights yeah you're not entitled to
anything
i'm sorry it hurts your feelings i
understand that and it does mean a lot
to you emotionally i hear you saying
that
but that doesn't give you any moral or
legal or even emotional rights to it
um we have a lake house and if i decide
to sell it tomorrow
it will break my kids heart because
they've all learned to ski there the
grandbabies have all spent time there we
all love it
it's the same kind of a thing it's an
emotional piece of property for us
it'll break my heart anthony anthony's
anthony's anthony would be crying he's
already
his eyes are already leaking i'm serious
that's where you learn to ski
exactly
hey he did he's quite a quite a water
skier now you should have seen him the
falls were amazing last weekend but the
uh
anyway the uh yeah that the point being
uh you know that you earn the right to
speak into this by having some money to
do something it's not just a matter of
offering support it's a matter of
hey if you ever gonna sell it i don't
want that to happen because i love it
so much please give me first rights and
would you mind even putting that in the
will
dad um and something like that that
would be okay
and there's nothing wrong with that at
all and so i got dibs on that you know
that that's a
if if you're gonna if you would allow me
to i would consider that awesome because
it means so much
to me but just because it was your
childhood
uh summer vacation and it's emotional
does not give you any rights
you're not you have zero entitlement on
that sorry